wo ist dein leben
[Musik]
ich habe doch nicht rund um die uhr um
am ende die hälfte meines gehalts zu
bekommen ich bin doch kein problem ich
kenne das nach abzug der steuer und der
versicherung bleibt vom bruttogehalt
nicht so viel übrig sollte mal schauen
ob alles stimmt also dass hier sind die
abzüge für die einkommenssteuer
das hier ist die krankenversicherung die
fremden versicherung und die
arbeitslosenversicherung und die
kirchensteuer war es die kirchensteuer
aber ich bin doch schon vor jahren aus
der kirche ausgetreten also wenn du
ausgetreten bist dann musst du auch
keine kirchensteuer bezahlen rufen an
und fragen nach
danke mache ich ist das die neue website
für ein paar klaren ja die website hat
schon viel verändert seit sie online ist
habe ich fast doppelt so viele kunden im
ernst das problem ist ich schaffe das
nicht mehr alleine
ich brauche hilfe im laden und in der
werkstatt um die kunden nicht mehr zu
verlieren
warum guckst du mich sorgen was hast du
vor
ich will dir einen vorschlag machen